Charles it is so good uh to see you
virtually but not as good as the last
time I saw you in Atlanta because you
were paying for everybody's drinks so
that was a better time Hey Hey listen
you know you you're one of my favorite
people I'm so proud of your success and
uh it's my pleasure to be on your
podcast it's gonna be awesome today
thank you thank you no I I respect so
many of the things that you do and most
importantly I respect how true you are
to what you think and what you say and
the conviction that you say those things
with so there is so much that I want to
talk to you about
um this is definitely going to be a a
very full 45-50 minutes for sure but I
do want to talk a little bit about this
idea of how you always are kind of
buying everybody's drinks and creating
an experience for everyone have you
always been like a giver like that
no no honestly be honest with you Taylor
Just when I got money uh I started doing
that and I'll tell you why because you
know growing up poor nobody ever bought
you anything
and you know my mom was a great lady my
grandmother my mom worked in the uh was
a maid and my grandmother worked in a
meat factory and they were two
incredible women but you know I didn't
realize we were poor till I got older
so now that I'm blessed and I make that
clear I'm blessed because of a stupid
basketball I got uh I'm so I have an
amazing life so
I don't want people ever paying for
drinks when they're with me I mean I
I've been so lucky and blessed and like
I say when I didn't have anything
don't try to buy me stuff now that I'm
loaded and so I said no I got all the
drinks I got the dinner and I got the
drinks just relax I needed your ass when
I was poor living in the projects don't
run up on me now tell me hey can I buy
you a drink no you can't buy me a drink
I'm good to go now and that's and that's
as honest as I can be you know nobody
bought me anything when I was poor but
now all of a sudden because of who I am
they want to buy me stuff I'm like no
it's too late now I need to be back in
those project days so and and not you
and I just feel good I mean because like
I say you know it's weird I'm almost 60
Taylor it's really weird I'll be 60 in a
couple months
you know I was talking to uh I was I was
with Dr J we were on the plane together
and I I remember
he was 35 him and Moses when I first got
to the NBA and we should call them
Gramps
and now I'm like 35 I'm like now I'm
like 59. yeah it's weird turning it's
weird turning 60. no for sure and I also
asked you as as you get older your
understanding of Age and what it means
to actually be old changes like now I
don't think that being 60 is being old
you still have so much more life that
you're living
I didn't know that I'm saying in in a
world where you're safe and healthy
right 60 is not old if everything goes
the way you would think you have lots of
Life to Live yes well so I look at it
like this
50 is my magic number anything after 50
is gravy I always tell people it's only
sad when young people die they didn't
get to experience life but I think if
you've been here 50 years you should
have accomplished something you should
have done something in your life so I
and I'm not being morbid or whatever
like every day I live past 60 I look
like man that's just gravy and listen I
like to live as long as possible
obviously but man I've had such an
amazing tremendous life I mean I think
about it growing up in the projects in
my little Hometown a couple thousand
people and
because of a stupid ball I go to Auburn
great decision
go to Philadelphia for eight years
go to Phoenix for four years my last
four years in Houston so 16 years
and then I've been blessed to work for
Turner for 22 years
because of a stupid basketball so man I
just I'm so lucky and blessed and
thankful
and thankful because you know
it's been just an amazing journey yeah
and hey it's been so much fun you know I
was I was blessed to speak at Bill
Russell's funeral
a couple months ago I was one of the
speakers meant a lot to me a shout out
to my one of my heroes
but the last thing we played
was you know first of all he had that
loud cackle
but his wife Janine wanted to play this
last sound bite for him and it was
really perfect because I I could play
the same one for myself
and he says I lived
and I died but I had a whole hell of a
lot of fun along the way and then he did
that that calculated Bill Russell does
and that's amazing for me like
I lived I'm gonna die but man I don't
have a hell of a lot of fun along this
journey it's been incredible yeah it's
been amazing and I mean okay it's been
great yeah no I think that's really
beautiful and a great Outlook and
perspective to have on it I do wonder
you know with you some of your peers
passing right being close to people that
have passed how has that changed your
relationship with death and even though
you're saying that right now the all
these days are gravy are you scared of
the actual dying does that make no not
at all not at all because you know
what's crazy like
I look at this crazy world we live in
and I think about those four kids in
Idaho who died
I think about uh all my gay and lesbian
and transgender friends got their Club
shot up in Colorado
a couple weeks ago
I look at the kid crazy kid who shot up
to Walmart and killed all his co-workers
and you just say to yourself man you
just hope you ain't around with some
crazy stuff happened
because we just don't know
and uh I just said like hey you know
what man I had a good run whatever
happens happens I mean
you know Taylor I am so I you know I sit
there sometimes like when I go back to
my hometown
I drive by the projects where I built uh
my mom and grandmother a house
and
I think about like man look at all the
things you've accomplished in your life
you know I go by my high school
and I make sure my teams look good I
said hey my high school teams and
basketball before they look good because
of Chuck I said and they had a great
season they lost in the playoffs but I
want to make sure those kids look good I
said I don't care if y'all ain't worth
the damn but y'all gonna look good and
uh you know stuff like that means a
great deal to me yeah because I I wanna
I think I I keep trying to do some good
stuff away from the court
um
because number one I've been blessed to
make a a ton of money and one of my
goals has been and I've done for the
last
I think
13 years my goal is to be to give a
million dollars a year away to charity
so I started obviously uh with my high
school
my college another school at Alabama I
did Wounded Warriors
and I just did my sixth year in a row
historically black colleges Spelman uh
so you know I did I've done three in
Alabama and three in Georgia because
those hbcus mean a great deal to me
and I'm really just want to keep giving
this stuff away because like I said I
have one daughter
she's a blessing got a grandson now
which officially means you're old when
you're a grandpa well my name is Big Pop
too I stole it from somebody uh this
summer I was at an award show uh Ernie
got an award
and I want to support him
and his little girl comes up and said Mr
Barkley can I take a picture with you I
said sure
how's it going to take the picture she
says my big pop and I saw this little
dude walking toward me I said damn
if that little dude's Big Pop I know I
can be big [ __ ] pop cause I'm actually
big
so big pop instead of Grandpa is what
they think I said wait who's this little
dude walking toward her she said oh
that's my big Pop I said well I got my
grandpa name now I said this little dude
can be big Pop I can be big pop so yeah
that shout out to Ernie for winning the
award but also shout out to the little
girl who gave me the nickname idea I
love that so much big pop so is it big
pop Chuck is it just big pop Big Pop oh
that's big pop now little Henry's not
talking yet but he's he he likes hanging
out so he sleeps here and I got a beer
in his other hand and we watch football
together I got him trained he sleeps
right here
he he watches a little bit then he falls
asleep and then I get my beer in my hand
and uh so we it's a good little picture
so two things you love a lot your
grandkids and some beer yes yes and
that's your perfect day
uh uh well you know depends on how the
game is going who I bet on that day so
if I win a bet it's a really perfect day
okay I love that to more perfect days uh
for you and Henry yes yes
um you know one thing you did that I
thought was really special and really
important was during your Hall of Fame
speech you gave time to recognize Sue
bird and Sylvia fowl's two absolute
greats in the women's game what led you
to sharing that moment with them
well
I think it's important when we
acknowledge Sylvia
ensue into the greatest female
basketball players ever
that was my only chance to get to talk
when I was introducing my mentor dick
Ebersole
you know dick ever saw is the man who
talked me into doing television
he was great and I told the story that
night I want to acknowledge those two
women first and foremost but when I was
introducing Mr ebersol I want you know
Taylor I remember so I originally was
going to go to NBC
uh because they had the NBA back then
and a friend of mine Michael Jackson
worked here at Turner
and he said he called me he said Chuck I
need a favor I said oh anything for you
brother what you need he said I need you
to meet with Turner I said well you know
Mike I'm going to uh NBC
he says
yeah I think I know that but do me a
favor it'll make me look good at work
and I'm saying you know what come on
down I said I'm coming on down
and I had we went out to dinner
and we started talking
and I've like man I'm really starting to
like these dudes I'm really starting to
like these dudes
then we go we start smoking some cigars
and now I'm feeling like hey so my goal
in the mind ambition on television is
now I don't want to cry wolf all the
time but when the things come up
socially I want to be able to talk about
them they're like you can talk about as
much as you want to as little as you
want to
when civil rights stuff happened social
unrest we can talk about it like anytime
you want to
hmm interesting
so I go back to my hotel
probably one two in the morning
I called my agent and I said hey Mark I
think I have a problem he said what's
the problem he says I said I think I
want to go to Turner he says what do you
want me to do
he says I tell you what let me sleep on
it
and I'll make a decision
I slept like an hour I called him back
like four in the morning I could do that
because he's my agent he better be on
the speed dog at any time yes yes I said
yo man I'm gonna go with Turner he says
I'll call ever so I said nope let me
call him man-to-man
and I told this story tonight the other
Hall of Fame introduction when he got in
he said to me
and I I was almost teared up telling him
because he had he had groomed me to he
talked to me because I had never thought
about television until he talked me into
it and we went to dinner a couple times
he said today he says
those guys at Turner are great you're
going to be great on television good
luck
and I was like what that's it and when
he said that it took all my heart ache
away from having to break the but him
just saying those guys at Turner are
great you're going to be great on
television if you ever need anything
reach out to me and from that like and
the rest like I say he means that much
to me no I love that and so you felt
like in this moment where you know there
was a lot of Spotlight even though
you're introing him you needed to give
Sue and Sylvia yes their shine as well
yes yeah no I thought that was a super
super important moment
um okay you you always have a lot to say
which I love so I'm gonna put some hats
on you okay
you are
NBA Commissioner for a day
tell me three things you would change
first
one of my pet peeves is ticket prices
you cannot raise your ticket prices if
you don't finish above 500.
first and foremost that would be my
first thing you cannot raise your ticket
prices if your team sucks
first and foremost that'd be my number
one thing
secondly we can't have this load
management
it's not fair to the fans
it's not fair to the game
you need to play
to make tens of millions of dollars to
play 82 basketball games
you know most of the time you know he
Adam changed the rules so you don't even
have to play back to back you need to
play all the games
uh those the first two things I would
say okay so can't can't up the ticket
prices if your team's below 500 and then
also no load management what's no no
load management
number three I would
probably
shorten the season
[Music]
plays 70 games
because you know they add in playoff
games you can make up the difference in
that and I wouldn't start the season
until Christmas
because number one
nothing can beat the NFL
it's on a whole nother planet
but college football is really popular
and significant also if you go back and
look at our ratings our highest ratings
ever
was because of the strike the season
then started to Christmas
and
everybody want to say people wanted
basketball back I said no had nothing to
do with that you're not competing with
college and the pros that was the big
difference we would still have the
entire schedule January or February
March April May June till ourselves and
there's no other sports realistically
during that time
we'd have our own isolated situation
and when you don't have competition
because listen
pro football and college football on a
whole nother level those people are
addicts they're going to love those two
sports
so the number one thing you can do is
avoid those starting at Christmas that's
my three suggestions do you think we see
a world where any of those three come
true genuinely asking
well I think they all should come true
to be honest with you Taylor because
listen but do you think that any of them
actually come to fruition
uh
the the number one thing that I would
say would be the ticket prices I mean
these guys now I wish they would stop
lying about the load management
they say was not good for your body I
said well first of all these guys been
playing basketball 82 games in raggedy
sneakers flying commercial if they can
do it for five thousand dollars I'm damn
sure you can do it for 50 million okay
I mean I'm like wait a minute these guys
have been playing basketball forever
they played in Chuck Taylor's and things
like that flew commercial through buses
and things like that and they happened
to play all the games we fly private we
got the best shoes we got the best
medical equipment but y'all still need
low management please stop it just say I
want to play it longer so I can make
more money that's all it is to be honest
about the load management you'd be like
okay fine because you know listen if you
load management you probably can get an
extra two or three years out of your
career yeah I'm small enough to know
that yeah but just say that just say Hey
listen hey I'd like to make 34 million
dollars a year too but just don't say
I'm low because you hear the guy as well
it's not healthy for your body blah blah
I like yo man we've been playing
basketball forever relax they got the
best stuff ever today don't don't just
just don't stop stop lying that's the
only thing but
oh God I really truly believe that
ticket thing
it's not fair to fans of your products
suck and you're still gonna raise their
ticket prices yeah and I don't actually
don't think it's an unusual ask
well you shouldn't read you shouldn't be
able to raise ticket prices if your team
sucks that ain't Fair
do you think that the NBA should adopt
you know that kind of a system of
regulating teams if they're bad
no I don't know if you can do that
because I don't want to do that because
it's not fair like I want the fans to
see LeBron
I want the fans to see Giannis uh you
know I want them to see KD so yeah so oh
and you asked me another thing if a guy
is suspended
I suspended for home games I don't
suspend that for road games because that
might be the only time okay that player
goes to that City
so if if there's a suspension this
happened quite a bit like
guys didn't get to play that's the only
time they gonna play there you know some
of these fans spend save up all their
money to see the one time the Golden
State Warrior they want to see Steph
play they want to see LeBron play they
want to see Giannis play
if God's Gonna load manage do it at home
but if guys are suspended the NBA says
okay you're suspended three games you're
on a three-game road trip you only gonna
play that team one time you're gonna sit
out three games at home those are couple
things that I like to see changed oh
I'm for your GM hat
do you want to be GM of the Sixers or
the Suns
wow
and then you have to tell me the two
things you would change
wow girl
okay you know so the six of the six
situation is
gonna come down and beat and Harden
plain and simple
they both like the playoffs are for
stars
the Suns is going to come down to Booker
and Aiden you know I love Chris Paul
they give me trouble they give me a hard
time on the show said all the time he's
the best leader in sports but you can't
expect your guy to be 38 39 year olds
because you saw last year he was great
early in the playoffs then he got tired
you can't expect that from a guy who's
38 39. it's going to come down to Booker
and Aiden really eating because book are
going to do his thing Aidan's got to
pick it up a little bit but
those are two question marks that you
asked me about those teams I mean the
jury is still out on James and Joelle
can they play together
it's interesting when you see they play
great separately
but they don't play well together and
Angels gonna have to grow up and learn
to be a dominant player I mean Booker
he's already a terrific player but
there's a lot of pressure on Aiden
because he's really got to pick it up
well then okay just just to push you on
that question then if you are looking at
the Suns and if you are the GM what's
the things that you would do to ensure
actual success for that Phoenix team
well well they are successful they made
it to the finals they had the best best
record in the NBA but first of all I
have Jay Crowder I can't believe Jay
Crowder is still sitting at home Jay
crowd is a heck of a player I mean I'm a
big J Crowder fan I can't believe he's
sitting at home right now not just him I
can't believe some of these other teams
ain't picked him up I'd pick his ass up
immediately if I'm in Milwaukee Bucks
because you're going to play against
Tatum and brown you need all the wings
you got you can't I mean so that'd be
the first thing I'd do okay but
you know it's kind of it's starting to
shape itself out right now
Boston Milwaukee or separating
themselves from the rest of the East now
the West man the West is going to be
interesting I I said on the show last
week I think Denver's gonna finish with
the best record I don't think Utah can
keep it up they'll start to come back to
earth yeah uh so I don't think they're
that but I think Denver
the Warriors of the Warriors at the
mercy of their young guys the young guys
are not playing great right now it's too
early to give up on them but man Watson
and kamenga got to pick it up yeah or or
the words are going to be done
so I want your opinion on a topic that
people around the NBA are discussing
right now and I think that in some ways
you can relate to it because throughout
your career both in college and
professionally there was always a lot of
conversation about your body there was a
lot of commentary about your weight or
your size and I think that unfortunately
that is happening to Zion a lot more uh
recently so much so that when he was
asked about Thanksgiving he felt like he
couldn't even answer the question uh for
fear of people talking about how he saw
that I was I was I was I was
disappointed
for him giving the public that much
power
Thanksgiving for eating you don't have
to worry about if people make fun of you
that's on them but you never give other
people power
first and foremost secondly
Design's got to get in shape
you can't
it's
I'm trying to phrase this
he can't keep getting hurt
because at some point his body is not
going to recover because man the body is
an amazing machine
I get an example for me Taylor
when I first got to the NBA
I was about 295 pounds I played in
college right around 300.
and uh I wasn't getting the pla but I
had success
she just if you have success over a week
that does not mean you're successful
because the game changes when you go
High School shape and college shape
College shape ain't NBA [ __ ] and you
know you got to get better at every
level so I was a number five pick in the
draft I wasn't getting to play
and the best thing ever happened to me
was Moses Malone me and Moses lived in
the same building
and I said Big Mo can I come see you
tonight I got some stuff I need to talk
to you about these young fella come on
up
and I went up to his penthouse
and uh I said big mo why am I not
getting to play he's old yeah Young
fella you're fat and you're lazy
and I said what he's just you fat and
you're lazy you're so overweight you
can't work hard and first of all I did
like all grown men do I cried a little
bit because it hurt my feelings
but wait hold on I will say I have to
stop you right there though only because
you crying to him saying that you're
you're fat
is how Zion must feel when people are
talking about him but then you can't
preface the opinion with I hate that he
take he's taking it personally because
anybody would take it personally if
someone no no no
the thing he took person about he's
worried about what people think he's
going to eat for Thanksgiving that that
was the part that he's like yo man you
eat what you want to eat that's the
point he's thinking that tells me he's
thinking about it too much like
everybody asks everybody what they're
having for Thanksgiving and he was
scared to answer the question because he
was worried about what other people were
gonna say no I think what you're saying
is accurate but I think that the
disappointment probably more so lies in
the fact that he has been so ridiculed
and under the microscope for his weight
that he feels he can't even he can't
participate in the fun hey
this is a deal we make with the devil
when you're famous everybody has an
opinion on you
listen
you don't I wouldn't change a thing but
part of part of this thing that we're in
yeah
that's the reason they pay you all that
money
for sure yeah but that's just the way
the game is played but the point I was
making was on somebody around him's got
to say yo man you got to get in shape
but see the problem with John is he's
got so much power already like they're
scared he's gonna leave in a couple
years like they had to make the big
decision where to give him all that
money this summer and they did yeah but
but now they got to worry about because
now these guys on television gonna be
like well they're not put enough around
him
he he can leave in x amount of years you
know that's the new thing in the NBA now
when a guy don't want to be somewhere
after X amount of years he moves
but John's got to look in the mirror and
says hey you know what
Brandon's playing great CJ's playing
great our bench is pretty good
I'm the one holding us back because I
have not been available the best
abilities availability
but he's got to look but he's got to
look in the mirror and says
I got to get in shape because I keep
breaking down yeah and as he breaks and
I think his weight does have something
to do with it because he's a big man
he's really explosive
but he's got to look in that mirror like
hey that [ __ ] hurt me
when he called me fat and lazy
but he said to me if you want to get in
shape I'll help you
so he says something Taylor he says well
let's lose
10 pounds
I get to 290
I can feel a difference already I get to
280
now I'm really starting to I'm starting
now
I get to 270. I get to 260. I get to
250.
and I actually got to 240 but I said you
know I don't feel good at 240 I don't
have no strength blah blah he says but
250 is your weight but this man made me
help me lose 50 pounds
and the rest is history
but it started out with an honest
conversation yeah and I wonder here I
think that's fair like I I agree with
what you're saying I think that it is
incredibly fair and within the scope of
the job for people to be talking about
Zion's I don't know lack of conditioning
or how his diet is holding back him as a
player or how he's too big right now to
be effective like I think all of those
are fair but I think there's a
difference in these like constructive
analytical comments and the jokes that
he receives yes and the jokes are to me
what is the problematic aspect of it and
because of that goes with the job that
goes with the job yes and no but you
could argue it's a little dangerous
sometimes when we say that a part of the
job is to be made fun of because it's
like but
unfortunately we can't control the
Internet true very true it like I don't
believe in social media personally
because it's just a bunch of losers who
are evil and mean-spirited yes I don't
because I don't even mind like uh if you
have an opinion it is fair that's fair
but some of the stuff that said is so
negative and so wrong yeah and so unfair
that's one reason no matter how much
money I've been offered I'm never gonna
do social media never
um
but I think Zion's a great kid I think
he got a chance of being a great player
but the first thing you got to do is
figure out his body yeah like if if when
I started working out with Moses
if somebody told me I had I could lose
50 pounds I would have said you're
freaking nuts
but
when I got down to 250 they couldn't the
rest was history
the rest was history and I'm hoping John
got good enough people around him say yo
man first of all the type of money these
guys are making today
he should already have a chef by now
he should have a chef who lives at his
house cooks him all his meals because
you know Taylor this money has gotten so
astronomical number one I'm not a hater
bless all these young guys whatever they
make but hey hey hey let me tell you
something
I got in shape for two million dollars
okay
if they were gonna I might not ever eat
again if they're gonna pay me 34 to 50
million my first contract was four years
two million dollars
and I got in shape for two million
dollars Taylor
the money these guys are making today if
they gave me a contract making 30 40
million dollars a year I said yeah I'm
never gonna eat again ever all right
Charles so uh listen I believe what
you're saying I listen I hear and I
think times are different I'm in if
someone is like get in shape and we will
take care of you you would do it I
believe that no question yeah I will say
this though just because you know I am
on social media unfortunately so I
understand
um maybe some narratives and discussion
that happen online
would you say there have been times in
your media career that you have had
moments that could be called
hypocritical
no because you don't think you've ever
been a hypocrite ever
never
because when I
because I've done stupid stuff I got
called on it these guys today don't want
to be called on it so if you if you want
to say I'm hypocritical that's fair but
I when I got called to the carpet when I
did something wrong these guys don't
want to be called to the carpet because
Shaq says I'm like Chuck you did this I
said yeah and I got called on the carpet
for it you if we don't call people out
when they do stuff wrong like yeah I I'm
from the old group like yeah when I did
stupid stuff you know they they said
Chuck quit doing stupid stuff like
today's generation when they do stupid
stuff to like yo man Charles is killing
me on TV that's just I said yeah Charles
got killed when he did stupid stuff am I
not supposed to call guys out when they
do stupid stuff you totally should you
got to do your job but be a hypocrite
being a hypocrite would mean there's
things that you have done before and
then you fault someone else for doing
them it doesn't necessarily mean because
I got faulted when I did it I got
faulted when I did it so
I don't have a double standard I said
yeah when I did that they called me out
and yeah I'm gonna call them out because
I'm not going to let it go because I did
something stupid I said when I did
stupid stuff they called me on it this
new generation they're like
they don't ever want to be called out on
anything which is really unfair
by them
because you know Dr J gave me the best
advice there because I went ballistic
the first time somebody media called me
out
he's the Chuck take a step back
he says it's the criticism true I said
what do you mean
he says you know sometimes when somebody
criticizes you is correct
and I and I and that probably was one of
the best because I think it was my third
year I was becoming a star and Dr J
taught me a lot he says take a step back
what was the criticism about he says is
this criticism true
and I said well okay okay because nobody
wants to be talked bad about let's get
that out the way but but sometimes you
do have you like okay I was wrong
and that's another thing about this
generation they cannot fix their lips to
say my fault I was wrong they cannot fix
their lips to say that I wanna I wanna
stay on this because this is like
fascinating to me because I've always
kind of wondered you know
how much of your experience maybe your
faulty or whatever right play a role
into the opinions that you form about
other players and also your perception
of this generation versus how whatever
it was like for you when you were in the
NBA yeah
do you think and I don't I don't I want
to be clear on this I don't think that
you did anything wrong here I think that
both people were right in how they felt
with the Klay Thompson situation
yeah I was disappointed in clay because
hold on for a second I mean I was
disappointed in clay because I went back
and looked at what I said okay clay was
the best two-way player in basketball
for a long time
and what I said was
he's still a good player he's never
going to be that guy again for two
reasons for three reasons h
Achilles and ACL
no player
gets better when they get older that's
that just doesn't happen but you every
player declines first and foremost as
they get older but you factor in an
Achilles and an ACL
you I said and like I say and we've
talked about this I says I didn't say
the guy was a bomb I said he's never
gonna be that guy again I was caught off
guard because I went back and looked I
said clay still a heck of a player but
he's never going to be that best to
guard in the NBA that he was for a long
time because of age Achilles and ACL and
I was disappointed that he overreacted
because he 100 overreacted because I
said he is still a good player but his
days of being the best two guard in the
NBA because I'ma tell you what happened
that night because I've been there
Devin Booker was kicking his ass
and when you get older and you like
this guy's kicking my hands there's
nothing I can do about it because that
was really hard for me
when I got older because I'm like this
dude can't play and he's kicking my ass
that happens to every great player
but then you could tell clay was
frustrated because he started talking
about the four rings which nobody can
ever take them four rings and he's one
of the best players ever but that night
Devin Booker was kicking his ass and
there was nothing he can do about it and
I saw the frustration and that's how I
came out I said you know uh Clay's gonna
have to understand he's got four Champs
he's a great great player but
because of AIDS Achilles ACL
there's nothing he can do about Devin
Booker at this stage of his career but
you know that like
and the reason this is interesting to me
is because it's like both things in
essence could be true right like you can
think that clay won't be the same player
but he can also have his feelings hurt
by you saying that and so calling it an
overreaction I think is more that was
his feeling about what it is you said
but what you said you're entitled to I
don't I don't think you did anything
wrong with that but I think that it's
hard to say that things we say aren't
personal when you're talking about
something that is so personal to someone
does that make 100 it's a hundred
percent but if he actually listened to
what I said I said Place one of the clay
because you know this is the thing that
annoys me about these players today
when I said
for five to seven years he was the best
two guard in the NBA offensive on
defense he never picked up the phone and
said damn Charles that's a really nice
compliment
but this is what I actually hate about
this generation
uh and this is honest I'm not gonna lie
to you ever
I can say nine great things about these
dudes
they call me on the one thing when I
call them out that's the thing that
annoys me the most
uh like I say clay who I like a lot as a
person never called me and said man
Charles somebody who knows basketball
calling me the best two guard offensive
defensively in the league for five to
seven years man that's a really nice
compliment he never called me he got my
number but the one thing where I was
actually making a basketball point a
true basketball point I might please I
was like yeah man
you're over 30. you have the ACL you're
an Achilles
those three things don't go great
together I say I didn't call him a bomb
I see he's still a heck of a player but
that one night I I saw I saw myself a
little bit like man getting older is no
joke see because that's the one thing
that sucks about sports
no when you get older you're still
playing against a little 20 year old kid
who first of all he's dominant rocks but
he can run and jump like a mofo and like
my last two years I was brutal in
Houston I couldn't play dead and
I had two good years in Houston in the
last two it was so frustrating because
I'm like these dudes can't even play
these dudes can't even play and there's
nothing I can do about it because
father time is undefeated it's gonna get
everybody yeah and honestly going off
that you know right now there's the
report that you know people at Carmelo
and I.T and Boogie they are determined
to make it back to the NBA and I mean
obviously have all had you know Great
Moments in their career they're great
people they're great players all those
things but I wonder what it has to be
like sitting at home watching a game and
thinking I can still do this and this
push and pull of you feeling that way
but knowing that none of the people in
those front offices think that
first of all there's two deaths
when you quit playing sports especially
you play like this guys who in and out
of League one or two years those don't
count but when you play you've been
great in college and grade in the pros
man this when it's over Taylor it's
traumatic
it's traumatic when it's over
I mean but there's nothing you can do it
comes for everybody but
the thing is for those guys
number one you don't even know if they
can still do it first and foremost
but also
what role do you want
you don't get
I said a few years ago I thought Carmelo
Anthony was the best
one of the best one-on-one players I've
ever seen in my life and he was
but
what what what role does he still want
to be treated like by like Carmelo
Anthony
like my I get his help but my last two
years in NBA I went to the coach I said
coach
let me come off the bench
[Music]
I thought about it Tate I'm not even
lying I thought about it for two weeks
wow I was like
damn
I'm not very good right now
maybe I can help the team if I play
against the second unit which I did
because there's a big deal between
playing against starters and bench
players
and I went to Rudy as a coach I want you
to start Kevin Willis he like
why would I do that as a coach
you're not hurting my feelings I I I'm a
big old boy here
Kevin's a better player at this stage of
his career than me
I thought about it I didn't think of
this I just said I didn't think of this
[ __ ] last night I've been thinking about
it for two weeks
he says if you want to do that we'll do
it it's the right thing to do I went to
Kevin as Kevin I told Coach
you should be starting your better
player at this stage of your career
and I think I can help the team coming
off the bench because I'll be playing
against lesser players
and it actually worked out I actually
played decent I mean I wasn't Charles
Barkley but I actually played pretty
decent but
Taylor I'ma tell you something man it is
when you're not when this thing is over
it sucks
so it sucks I've heard that before from
athletes when they say you know you died
two deaths
um and I told I I get it but I think
it's really
powerful to think about what that
actually means like when you use the
word you know death for that first one
why is that the accurate term for how
you feel when you stop
because it's you know it's something
you've done since you were probably 12
years old
I mean you've been a basketball player
yo like like I probably start at 15 16
somewhere now I think I was 38 when I
retired and then you don't play
basketball anymore that's why it's like
death because let me tell you something
all these fools like once you come to
the rec center and play
you want me to come and play against a
bunch of electricians and plumbers and I
used to play against Karl Malone and
Michael Jordan that won't do nothing for
me no disrespect to plumbers and
electricians they're important
significant but I don't want to play
basketball against them
like I remember like sometimes I'll be
in the gym watching regular people play
and I'm like
nah I'm never no no no no no I'm not I
don't this is not attractive to me
whatsoever yeah I'm like I'm just sit
I'm sitting because most of the time I'm
just laughing
because you realize like damn I was
really good at basketball
when did you I was like when did you
stop
defining Yourself by basketball
well I think
you know that's kind of going to that
death thing that we talked about a
little bit earlier like
when you stop playing it's over
like it's over
like you can you can walk around like
your Charles Barkley or Carl Malone or
Patrick Ewing or Michael Jordan ever but
you just like you're just a guy and like
nobody can take away what you accomplish
but it's over the day you step off that
basketball court
I mean and it's it's amazing it's fun
it's awesome it's special
but then one day you wake up and like
it's over
so and go ahead
and it and it's traumatic yeah it's a
traumatic thing for you
so well I think that
um we might think we know the answer I
would love to actually hear the answer
which phase of your life
has made you the happiest or more at
peace is it basketball Charles Barkley
or has it been media Charles Barkley
Taylor
ain't nothing like playing a sport and
being great at it and nothing I don't
care what happens on television
there's nothing like like this weekend
you know I was watching all the rivalry
games like
I'm sitting there watching Ohio State
Michigan
Washington Alabama Auburn Lake being a
player in that environment
where the whole state your Stadium's
like counting on you to make their day
good
does nothing like it and then when
you're in the NBA
when you're when your team is having a
great season you're doing well in the
playoffs the city's on fire people
forget people forget about all the
problems and Bs going on in their life
for two hours you can like make them
happy there's nothing like it
like people you know you people like you
know I'm going through this I'm going
through that but man for two hours
or doing a playoff run like everybody's
happy the city's on
ain't nothing like playing a sport for a
living
and I mean
you were a hell of a player and I think
in my opinion you tell me if you agree
some people have forgotten how good you
were especially those that were younger
who like you know they hear how good
Charles Barkley was but to them you're
the person on TNT that talks about
basketball do you think in some ways
people have forgotten who Chuck was on
the court
you know that's a great question you
know but In fairness you know Taylor I'm
in my 22nd year
on TNT so
anybody think about it
most of these people ain't been alive
uh you know I mean but I was born the
year uh that you were traded to the sons
actually but I already know how good you
were yeah but but you know listen my
what I accomplished was I'm really happy
with my career the only thing I was
missing was a championship wish I could
have got that for the city of Arizona uh
the State of Arizona excuse me you know
Philadelphia had gotten one the Houston
that got one I that was probably not
getting the sons one was probably my
biggest
regret more than anything but like
I don't think about
my past as far as like people recognize
it or not
because like we forget everybody I had
this argument
with this guy that argument this guy I
don't even know his name I came up to me
actually I think like five days ago he
says
why do y'all not mention Wilt
Chamberlain as the greatest ever I said
well first of all
I'm a 76er I Love Will Chamberlain
uh and I met I got to meet him twice and
it was amazing but I said but you got to
be I realized something all these people
who are talking about sports today have
never seen Wilt Chamberlain play
so
I think
once you know
it's just that's just a part of
evolution where most of the guys
on girls on television
they never seen most of these guys play
they don't know how great Bill Russell
was Oscar Robertson
I think uh let's be realistic I only
seen those guys in tapes myself yeah my
first recollection of NBA is probably
Bird magic
uh and most people they think about that
I mean I don't think I really started
paying attention to the NBA until bird
and Magic made it popular I think my
first recollection of really college
basketball was that year in March
Madness when they were talking about
when they wanted to still probably think
the most watched game in the history of
college basketball so I mean to that to
that point like as you talked about you
know championships
do you think it's fair for there to be
this like ding on your career because
you didn't win a ring
I think it's really
unfair because I don't know when it
became an individual thing
but what's happening
we've given these guys
see I'm not sure morning
talk shows are the best thing for sports
because
they make you a bust or a success
quickly
you know again I get an example
you look at Troy Aikman
and Peyton Manning
two of the greatest quarterbacks ever
I think they both went 1-15 their first
year
in in the NFL
do you know what would happen if the
number one quarterbacks went one in 15
in today's television network loud
voices in the morning what a bus what a
bomb I mean like
because people are brainwashed by what
they hear on television
we we call guys bus after six weeks now
we we call guys bombs after six weeks
but I will say I will say Chuck because
I I do I'm really interested in how it
has affected you personally for this
because I didn't think that is an effect
on me
yeah I'm talking about the championship
thing because I agree it is unfair to
ding people for like not winning the
ring but that gold but that that goes
back to we're talking about earlier
that's the job yeah like that goes I
have to take I don't get to take just
the good stuff
like
when you're in the Limelight for some
reason the area idiot fooling jackass
feel like they got a computer
they got a comment
on somebody
I you know I read stories like people
talking about they talking about how
they kids dress and things like them
like why is that your business why you
got to comment on that but
that's part of the job when you're
famous everybody has no pain about you
I think the conversation around you
would be different if you did have that
ring because you're saying it's unfair
it's not an individual thing
well that would be the only only knock
it would be like my my resume is
complete yeah uh that that would be the
only thing but let me just tell you this
I would never I talked to you earlier
about giving Foods power
I would never give anybody the power to
say my life was not successful because I
didn't win another basketball game
that's never gonna happen yeah you know
when I speak when I speak to kids I do a
lot of speaking at high schools
to teams and college team and actually
pro teams also
and I talked to them about self-esteem
I said yo man it's called self-esteem
not with all these other fools think of
you it's called self-esteem I'm very
happy
but what I accomplished in basketball
uh like I say the only thing I didn't do
was win the championship I knew I was
great I knew I was great nobody has to
tell me I know I'm good absolutely yeah
but but if people want to say mean
Karl Malone John Stockton Patrick Ewing
AI aai
uh Russell Westbrook right now going
through it who can he's a great great
player uh James Harden's a great great
player jail and B's a great great player
but just because some fool in the
morning on a talk show says he never won
the championship I'm like well first of
all you never played let's get that out
the way but I would never give them that
power to make me feel like less of a a
player absolutely no I agree with that
and it's like does not winning the ring
diminish your talent and what you were
able to do I don't think it did so yeah
because I'm like
just because guys get paid to talk about
people on television like
they're paying number one don't matter
to me but like wait it's not an
individual sport yeah yeah but that that
but you're only gonna get
the way this whole thing works you're
only going to get attention if you're a
butchering Stars that's the way the
thing works because you know Taylor you
ain't never heard Statics of bottles
didn't win the championship
you ain't never heard uh Dan Marley one
of my best friends it's like the only
way to sustain an argument and get
clicks is I've got to go after the Stars
well yeah because you can argue the
reason the person not winning a ring is
even a conversation is because you feel
as though they could went away like it
is almost a mark of like I think you are
talented enough like yeah
it's called big game hunting yeah like
the best way to get clicks and to get
attention is go out to the bigger stars
in every sport that's just but like I
say that's the way the game works now
well I'm speaking I'm sorry speaking of
big stars uh you went on you went on Tom
Brady's show I I think last week maybe
and you talked about how you haven't
spoken to Michael Jordan for 10 years
because of something that you said on
air
um yes who knows if Michael Jordan saw
that podcast but right now if Michael
Jordan was right here what is the thing
that you would say because I know you
said he was your best friend you guys
haven't spoken you didn't love that what
would you say to Michael Jordan it's a
really unfortunate situation for me and
him
but you know Taylor I'm gonna do my job
first and foremost because I can't
criticize other coaches and general
managers
and give him a pass because he's my best
friend I just can't do that
and what I said was I wasn't sure I said
Michael got to surround himself with
better people
that's what you said on air yes and I
said I worry about him being successful
because when you're a star especially
because he because he's the biggest star
I've ever been around
everybody around you is going to tell
you what you want to hear
and I I didn't think he had a good
enough support and cast around him in
the front office
to be successful
and I said that
and had no problem saying it because it
was the truth and he took offense
and he called me and it wasn't a
pleasant conversation and we haven't
spoken since then but did you know after
that phone call y'all likely wouldn't
talk for a while
that's a great question
um
I thought it would blow over to be
honest with you
to be honest with you
and he's stubborn and I'm stubborn
and that's it
but right now because I know you are a
person who does you know lead with
compassion and I know that you do really
cherish your friends if you had the
opportunity to talk to Michael now what
is it that you would you would say to
mend that
uh I probably would say Hey you know
what I said was I believed
I'm sorry you took offense to it
and
let's get past this [ __ ] and go back
to playing golf and having fun yeah I
would think so because just the nature
of of the business I would assume
there's been times even though you
haven't spoken in 10 years y'all had to
have been in the same room in 10 years
yes
we have been and so in those rooms you
just don't speak
yes that's so sad
it's unfortunate it is sad and it's
unfortunate but we have been in the room
I think five times yeah and just walk
past each other
yes that's a good way to explain it all
right Chuck next time you're in the room
with Mike I want you're gonna be a big
person here and you're on a Min the
relationship well I appreciate that Dr
Dr Ruth that's our goal that's going to
be our goal
um so a couple more for you but before I
let you know uh I spoke to Kevin Durant
today I told him that I was interviewing
you and I asked him if he had a question
that he wanted to ask you and he does
have one would you like to hear it yes
Katie's question was
is money your only motive in life
money uh I think that money is important
because you get to do great stuff with
it
but I'm way past worrying about money at
this stage of my life to be honest with
you but but I think it's really
important
because
what what I what I really want to do is
I think I've really done a fantastic job
of giving back
it really means a lot to me
it really means a lot to me to give back
because
you know the one thing that bothers me
about America the greatest country in
the world
there is racism
always has been and always will be
but
we need to always address it when it
happens what is anti-Semitic uh if it
happened to Asian there's a lot of Asian
hate going on out there it's a lot of
gay hate transgender hate going on we
need to address those two I'm always
supporting my gay friends and trans
transgender friends you know we talk
about that a lot on me and Ernie's
podcasts
but
the biggest problem I think in America
is economics
it's rich people against poor people
and one thing that I try to do more
important thing is
the last six years I've given a million
dollars to historically black colleges
and I'm gonna keep doing that because
one of the travesties of our country is
what it costs to go to college now it's
a joke and a disgrace
that we're paying all that these kids
have to pay x amount of money to go to
college is a joke but what I try to do
with my little small little piece
is I really want to try to make a
difference
uh
economically for poor people
and I'm gonna keep doing my part so the
money's not even close to the most
important thing
but it's important depending on what you
do with it like I drive a Kia
you know it's so funny when you talk to
kids they're like what kind of car you
got I'm like I got a Kia they're like
because they want you to say I got a
Mercedes or something like that I'm like
no dude I got a Kia I will tell you
right I love it it gets me the same
place as those cars those Porsches and
those Beamers and things gives me the
same place
why do you think is I didn't I didn't
ask him so I don't know why do you think
that was the question that Kevin wanted
to ask you
if most money was the only motive in
life no no no no no no uh I actually
like Kevin I think that
he's a great player
I think he's actually a good dude I
think he's insecure at times
because I think
you have to realize
sometimes criticism like I told you
earlier sometimes criticisms are fair
and he got mad at me because and doesn't
bother me because my point was
you know there's a really big difference
to being the bus driver than the bus
rider that's what everybody on the bus
is important but the mental stress
the leadership
or does all the part of being the man
the stress of
dealing with not winning
keeping a locker room together
dealing with that stuff every night
every game that's is stressful
and one of the reason you know he gets
mad when the old guys like myself saying
he got to win a championship away from
the Golden State Warriors
before he gets you know to for for his
level to grow and I know he got offended
by that but that's not my job to worry
about people's feelings my job because
when I'm on television I'm really
talking to the public I'm not talking
like I can't go on TV and try to protect
the players and the coaches and general
managers like I wanted people at home to
know what's going on and that's always
going to be my focus and I mean total I
know obviously every media person has a
job to do your job is to literally give
your opinion right I'm in no way faulty
on that you should be able to say
exactly what you think about whatever
player it is I think that to play a bit
of Devil's Advocate and also because
I've had so many conversations with
Kevin more so about perception that
happens
um I think the issue that comes
sometimes from players and people in the
media is for example right now for you
to say I think he's insecure right it's
like what data have we collected or what
have conversation you had with him
personally to be able to label him as an
insecure person and so then I think that
when he's always being told he's these
things
your your automatic reaction is going to
be okay well I need to tell you what I
actually am and I think that's why a lot
of fans do sometimes enjoy this like
going back with him going back and forth
with him online because it's the one
time that a person can tell you who they
are as opposed to somebody who isn't
them trying to tell you the ins and outs
of what they are doing on the court or
who they are as a person does that make
sense yeah yeah I understand that but
the reason I say he's insecure Taylor
there's levels to this you don't have to
react to every fool like when you're
arguing with a 16 year old kid
that's like yo man why are you worried
about a 16 year old kid like
I don't
get I don't talk to that many people
that are like like every idiot fool
jackass that says something to me I
don't respond
I'm like yo man I don't care what you
think uh so that would make you that
that makes you insecure like if it's
somebody I admire and respect like okay
I'll listen to you but my when I talk
about insecurities like yo man
everybody's opinion doesn't matter
it does not uh so like
you know when I was like when my man's
got you know man you don't need burner
phones you're Kevin Durant you can say
whatever the hell you want to but you
don't have to react to every single
thing
and like so that's why I think some of
his insecurities come in from
do you feel like there really is that
much of a difference between
the way players acted and your
generation and the way players act now
or is there just more things available
now for people to see how they act
because when I hear stories about times
when you were playing or certain things
like you know things that you have done
or Shaq has done all things that I love
and I think are funny they're not much
different than what players are doing
right now well I think the difference is
they overreact like
number one I never talk about anybody's
personal life
never I don't care even if it's been
proven true I don't comment on their
personal life
I always stick strictly to basketball
and the situation at hand
but like I say these guys
they don't think they can be criticized
I've been criticized Michael Jordan
being criticized lab bird being
criticized Magic Johnson being
criticized I mean remember I forget my
magic played bad one year they call him
tragic Johnson in the playoffs he didn't
get mad but why do you think players
didn't get like I guess it's hard for me
and I'm genuinely asking you your
opinion it's hard for me to believe that
just because people were born in
different times that they didn't go bad
when they were criticized because I
don't believe that you weren't mad if
you were criticized I don't believe
anyone's not a little mad what you have
to ask yourself no but I'm saying though
I go back to what I said my conversation
with Dr J
you have to ask yourself it's a
criticism Fair
that I don't think
look I don't think these guys ever take
the time to like
it's a criticism Fair they're like no he
criticized me I gotta go back at him on
social media or on television I wish
some of the time they're like
yo man
okay that's a fair criticism but I don't
think they believe that today
uh they think that because
you know and I think that and it ain't
in that time you criticize guys to oh
get off my long guy like no dude you can
be criticized everybody's been
criticized before
I mean I I played doing the Michael
Jordan era and remember like that's how
old I am like oh he can't win you can't
win with him doing that I'm like
okay then he won
but like
uh everybody gets criticized but the
problem is when you criticize guys today
man they take it so personally
which is fine I don't mind them getting
mad I don't well how do you think how do
you think you would have reacted to it
to Charles Barkley how would Charles
Barkley have reacted to TNT Charles
Barkley genuinely asking
uh well that goes back to what I said
earlier okay it's a criticism Fair
because
I never had when players call me
when coaches call me when general
managers called me
we first of all I talked to
15 guys a week whether they're a player
coaches general managers their
conversation is always private I've
never I would never disclose a private
conversation
ever
but they and I said well this is why I
said this
and 90 of the time they're like it
wasn't a personal shot dude you saw what
just happened in the game
and that's probably one I tell you in a
funny story
uh say one night remember the night Kobe
Bryant wouldn't shoot the basketball
against the Suns one year
I went off on him after the game I said
Hey listen we all big Kobe Bryant's fans
but what he did tonight was just total
[ __ ] he wouldn't shoot the ball he
was trying to prove I think he shot one
time in the second half
and it and it was brutal I mean he was
just trying to prove a point he didn't
have any help
so he starts texting me after the game
calling me every freaking name in the
book
and this goes on for about three hours
that's like four or five o'clock in the
morning now you know we worked at like 1
32. and he's as young man pick up the
freaking phone and talk to me but he was
calling me every name in the book
you've had a lot of calls after the show
uh
uh probably
probably in in 22 years probably 10
calls right after the show
what's a call that would surprise me you
don't have to tell me about the
conversation but who's someone who
called you and you were surprised they
took offense by something you said well
there's been a cup of coaching decisions
I a couple coaches call me I said you
didn't do that right you didn't do that
right but so you've gotten a call from
MJ you've got a call from Kobe who's one
more that you can just recall called you
due to something you said
I don't even remember to be honest with
you because I haven't got a call I mean
because man God Rest in Peace Kobe that
I'm trying to think that was so long ago
but that was that was really one of the
funniest nights of my life because I get
back to the hotel
and it's like 2 30.
and we text each other probably another
10 15 times well his texts were like
he cursing me out
I'm like yo man I explained to you why I
said what I said
and then like I said when we saw each
other next year he said yo man you know
what you were right and that's the thing
I remind about Kobe he says Chuck you
was right and I was wrong I said yo man
I love you you were wrong that night
I'm not trying to these kids today
counsel anybody like
but you know it goes back to a point I
made you earlier
I get
so offended at times
when an agent calls me or a coach calls
me
Isis young man I
been bragging on your player
for years
and the one time I criticized him you
freaking blow up my phone yeah that that
that's the thing that probably annoys me
the most to be honest with you
like I'm like yo man why don't you have
a call message Chuck thank you for the
kind words about my player you know
Aaron Goodwin
is somebody that we text and go back and
forth he'll always come and say hey man
thanks for talking good about my player
and I'm like of course man it's but
I'm trying to think there's been a
couple agents uh you know bam out of
BIOS uh a couple years ago I was
bragging I said this dude don't make the
All-Star team it's a travesty and a
disgrace
and I got a call from the heat saying
thank you blah blah blah then his mom
says then I saw his mom at the All-Star
Game she gave me she said I just want to
thank you you're the only person who
said my you said I'm saying my son
should make the All-Star team and I
started saying it like
three months before the thing like right
now let me tell you something right now
Shay gildren Alexander better be
starting in the damn All-Star Game this
year I'm saying that right now on your
part you got it she should be and also
you're saying something nice it's on
record starters also a starter yes well
you know what Chuck I was gonna say on
this this Spirit of positivity because I
know you have to go I want to ask you
one more question sure and we're gonna
call it the be nice challenge okay I'm
gonna say three players and you have to
say one nice thing about each of them
okay are you ready yes who do I want to
do I'm like looking at who's okay
one nice thing about Ben Simmons
one nice thing about Anthony Davis and
one nice thing about Kyrie Irving
okay
Ben Simmons
is a
very talented player
I said a few years ago
he can't be a great player until he
learns how to shoot
I says he can be a really good player
I will say this the challenge is being
nice all of these things have to become
no no no no no no no no no because
it see see see the problem I have with
your question is
it's layered
Ben Simmons I said he's a he's a really
good player but he can't be a great
player until you learn how to shoot
Anthony Davis has probably been the most
disappointing to me to be honest with
you
I said five or six years ago
that guy's gonna be the best player in
the world
I said that guy right there is going to
be the and I really meant that a hundred
percent
and to see where he's at now is
disappointing
I went out on a limb and said that guy's
gonna be the best basketball player in
the world
and now he's not even mentioned
Kyrie Irving is one of the best
one-on-one basketball players I've ever
seen
his ability to dribble and shoot
are incredible
but
you know what Taylor
it's a team game
I have to look around at my brothers
and say oh
I'm doing it with him him and him
and that's my biggest problem with Kyrie
he's a great player
but
we have an obligation
to the guys in the locker room they're
in there practicing hours a day
they're lifting weights
they're shooting
they're doing wince prints and
everything during the summer to get
ready for the season you don't do this
thing by yourself
so
all three of those guys got a lot of
Pros but they got some cons too so your
question is great your little be nice
thing is great
yeah but you can't
it's like my life in your life
I always sign autographs you do I've
never seen you turn one down I always
take pictures and it's annoying as [ __ ]
sometime sometimes I'm trying to eat
but you know what
that's that's part of the gig you don't
get all the good stuff
like you've been a woman a black woman
talking Sports
there's going to be some hate and
animosity towards you just because
you're a woman
and that just goes with the gig yeah and
like we know what I always tell people
though
it damn sure beats working
you know we do have a good life we talk
about sports and we get paid I know I
tell people all the time they're like
yeah man don't you get tired of the
autographed pictures sometimes I do and
then and listen
if my friends
feel the need to share social media with
me I'm like yeah man I got a life I
ain't got time to be sitting around and
reading the internet I got stuff going
on don't be bringing it to me if I
wanted to follow it I read it myself I
mean in their defense there are some
funny like Charles Barkley memes and get
like they're so funny
Hey listen and like I say I signed up
for the gig and I'm gonna tell you
something
I take the good with the bad I don't get
like when we go on the road in the
playoffs I don't give a damn who wins
but
in one city they love me
and the other City they hate me I said
and they I like yo man I don't care who
wins
that's the thing that makes me laugh the
most probably like you don't like our
team that's your man I don't like I
don't care about you or your team but
the fans but fans you know the best
advice I got was for my mentor dick
Ebersole
and and he's been 100 correct 22 years
later he says
you're gonna be great on television
he said you're always going to be in
trouble though
I said what does that mean he says
you got to understand something about
television people don't want you know
when people said they want the truth
they really don't want the truth what
people want is hey tell me my favorite
player is great
and tell me my team is great that's what
fans want they don't like your man your
favorite player is not that good and
your team sucks
from that point on
they ain't hearing nothing you say they
pissed at you but but that's the job I
signed up for Taylor and I'm so lucky
and I'm so lucky and blessed to have
this job
I get to work with Kenny and Shaq and
Ernie
and all the amazing people at Turner you
know the people about you know when you
got a gig the people behind the scenes
work twice as hard as we do yeah so I
really I'm blessed to work with the most
amazing people
well I will say even though you're
saying you know you you learn to believe
and know that not everyone's gonna like
you you are somebody who is so loved
within Sports you're on literally the
greatest sports show of all time you
were in people's homes every week I know
people love watching you so thank you so
much for coming on this show you were a
pleasure I feel like I had so many
really good conversations where I
actually learned some things about you
so I really appreciate your time and I
feel so lucky that I get to work with
you all the time as well well you know
I'm so proud of your success I want you
to keep pushing the envelope we need
more of you out there because you're
very talented I mean obviously you know
people can see your beauty but they need
to look past and see how talented you
are I'm proud of your success and keep
it going I appreciate that Chuck I will
see you in Atlanta drinks on you
bye hey hey hey Taylor I hit a lot more
now
[Laughter]
hey give me some of that contract money
by the way but we'll talk
take care bye
[Music]